Buenas tardes pues simplifica simplifica
el ingreso de bienes y de alimentos
frescos a Irlanda del Norte acabando con
el papeleo con la burocracia y los
controles actualmente por ejemplo el
envío de una salchichas frescas que es
un producto bien importante para la
dieta nacional desde Londres a belfas el
mismo país es casi que un trámite de
importación por la cantidad de
burocracia de papeleo y de controles que
requería y el gran anuncio hoy es que
esto se va a acabar aumentando entonces
la presencia de productos británicos
frescos en los supermercados para acabar
con ese desabastecimiento que ha sido
una de las constantes desde que el
brexit se hizo efectivo hace tres años
el Primer Ministro ha dicho que se
elimina cualquier sentido de frontera en
el mar de Irlanda entonces además habrá
también más disponibilidad de medicinas
esto es bien importante cada vez que la
autoridad de medicamentos británico
apruebe un nuevo medica tú este estará
inmediatamente disponible en las
droguerías y en los hospitales de
Irlanda del Norte las decisiones sobre
el IVA y sobre los impuestos estarán a
cargo del gobierno central en Londres
ahora viene una parte bien compleja para
el Primer Ministro y es tratar de vender
este acuerdo en el parlamento
necesita dos apoyos bien importantes
primero los de los eurocépticos de su
partido el partido conservador que como
sabemos tantos dolores de cabeza han
causado a los antecesores de sunat Por
no querer tener ningún tipo de relación
con la Unión Europea y también con los
sosionistas de Irlanda del Norte que son
fundamentales para que se restablezca el
poder político en belfast en Irlanda del
Norte Así que empieza esta noche la
carrera de Richie sunak por tratar de
convencer a su partido al parlamento a
los unionistas de Irlanda del Norte que
este es el mejor acuerdo que pudieron
lograr entre Londres y Bruselas Luisa
Muchas gracias vamos ahora con la otra
parte con la europea Esther Herrera
desde Bruselas le pregunto Qué
concesiones ha hecho la Unión Europea
para alcanzar este acuerdo
la verdad es que después de dos años en
que apenas se han movido las posiciones
la Unión Europea se ha flexibilizado en
una de las cuestiones que hasta ahora
siempre se había negado los predecesores
de sunaki se trata de que la asamblea de
stormond que es el parlamento Regional
de Irlanda del Norte tenga voz y voto
para decidir cambios en regulaciones y
en normas europeas que se considere
afecten a la región por ejemplo en la
entrada de bienes si consideran que es
perjudicial para Irlanda del Norte
además Londres tendrá derecho abeto en
caso de que se active este freno de
emergencia que da más poder a Irlanda
del Norte y también más derechos y más
para decidir Su futuro asegurado también
el Primer Ministro Richie sunak además
los tribunales de Irlanda del Norte
tendrán en una primera instancia poder
abordar cuestiones disputas comerciales
que afecten en sus relaciones con la
Unión Europea aún así el tribunal de
justicia de la Unión Europea seguirá
teniendo la última voz porque en última
el que habla En nombre del derecho
europeo y también en el nombre del
mercado único esta cuestión el papel del
tribunal de justicia de la Unión Europea
es una de las cuestiones que habían
envenenado más las relaciones entre
Londres y Bruselas pero aún así es una
mayor concesión así lo ha admitido la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
fonder Legend pero dice que las
concesiones son necesarias en Pos de la
estabilidad y a favor de la paz en
Irlanda del Norte pero para Bruselas
todo esto se trata de un nuevo capítulo
en las relaciones entre Londres y
Bruselas se trata de algo histórico Y
eso se ha podido ver claramente en el
buen entendimiento y en las buenas
palabras que han mantenido tanto sunat
como fonderlation